dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly zsolnai-fehér from
many fond childhood memories most of us
are quite fond of the colorful physical
appearance of bubbles and fuel water
mixtures we also know surprisingly
little about this peculiar phenomenon
where the color of an object changes
when we either turn our head or change
the lighting this happens in a very
colourful manner and physicists like to
call this iridescent or go neo
chromosome what is even less known is
that if we try to use a light simulation
program to make an image with leather
we'll be surprised to see that it also
shows a pronounced corneal chromatic
effect and even more or less known fact
is that quite a few birds insects
minerals seashells and even some fruits
are iridescent as well I've added links
to some really cool additional readings
to the video description for your
enjoyment this effect is caused by
materials that scatter different colors
of light in different directions
a white incoming light is therefore
scattered not in one direction but in a
number of different directions sorted by
their colors this is why we get these
beautiful rainbow coloured patterns that
we all love so much now that we know
what iridescent is the next step is
obviously to infuse our life simulation
programs to have this awesome feature
this paper is about simulating this
effect with micro facets which are tiny
micro structures on the surface of rough
objects and with this it is now suddenly
possible to put a thin iridescent film
onto a virtual object and create a
photorealistic image out of it if you
are into math and would like to read
about some tasty spectral integration in
the frequency space with Fourier
transforms this paper is for you if you
are not a mathematician also make sure
to have a look because the production
quality of this paper is through the
roof the methodology derivation
comparisons are all really crisp loving
it if you have a look you will get a
glimpse of what it takes to create a
work of this quality this is one of the
best papers in photorealistic rendering
I've seen in a while in the meantime I
am getting more and more messages from
you
scholars who tell their stories on how
they chose to turn their lives around
and started studying science because of
this series wow that's incredibly
humbling and I really don't know how to
express my joy for this I always say
that it's so great to be a part of the
future and I am delighted to see that
some of you want to be a part of the
future and not only as an observer but
as a research scientist this sort of
impact is stronger than the absolute
best case scenario I have ever dreamed
of for the series thanks for watching
and for your generous support now see
you next time
[Music]
you